hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to talk
about is how to use the difference
quotient at a particular point so I'll
have a link to one of my other videos
about how to just use a difference
quotient in general and that just gives
you a formula for the slope of the
tangent line any pull anywhere along the
graph at any point but here what we're
gonna do is we're gonna find the
difference quotient at just one
particular point so it's not a general
form it's giving you that slope at that
one particular point so here's the
formula were going to be using right
here it's f of a plus h minus F of a
divided by H and it's the limit as H
approaches zero okay now a is the
x-coordinate of the point that you're
interested in finding the slope at okay
the instantaneous rate of change and
just to show you a quick refresher here
what we have is we have our point a okay
comma F of a ok meaning if you put that
a value into your function that's the Y
value okay and if you go just a little
distance to the right we'll call that
distance H okay so from the origin to
here this is a plus H okay so that's the
x-coordinate at this point if you put
that x-coordinate into your function you
get f of a plus h so you're with me so
far now what we're going to do is we're
just going to do the slope formula so
we're going to do y2 minus y1 divided by
x2 minus x1 and that's how you get this
formula so it's just reduced down a
little bit so let's go ahead and jump
into some examples what we're going to
do is we're going to find out the slope
okay at this point 1 comma 2 now I
always like to draw a picture this is
just me I just like to see what's going
on you don't have to do this but just to
understand a little bit better this is a
square root function that's been shifted
left 3 so 1 2 3 and it looks something
like that okay now we're interested in
at 1 comma 2 which is going to be right
about there we're interested in what's
the slope okay of the tangent line the
line that just bear
really touches that function at that one
point one comma two so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna go ahead and use this
formula over here we've got square root
okay of one plus h plus three okay minus
F of 1 which is 1 plus 3 square root of
4 is going to give us 2 all divided by H
and we're looking at the limit as H
approaches 0 okay so you're with me so
far so all I did was I put a plus h in
this case a is 1 so I put 1 plus h in
place of X and I put 1 in place of X
here
okay that's Apple 1 and that gives you
the square root of 4 which is 2 now the
only thing we have to do now is we just
have to simplify this a little bit
further going to use the rationalizing
technique so what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to multiply the numerator
and the denominator by the conjugate so
this is 1 plus h plus 3 plus 2 and I'm
going to do the same thing to the
denominator as well 1 plus h plus 3 plus
2 so you see the sign here - I'm making
this plus whatever I multiply the
numerator by when I multiply the
denominator by so I don't change the
overall value of this fraction so what
we're going to do is we're going to
distribute or foil so we've got the
first term in the first term that's just
going to give us 1 plus h plus 3
whenever you multiply a square root
times itself you just get what's
underneath now the inside terms and the
outside terms those are going to cancel
because once positive and ones negative
and then the last terms we have a
negative 2 times a positive 2 which is a
negative 4 and this is all divided by H
times this quantity right here so this
is 1 plus h plus 3 plus 2 okay now if I
simplify this down a little bit further
what do we get we've got 3 minus 4 which
is negative 1 plus 1 is 0 so those are
cancelling out we've got each divided by
H so that's going to be your let's
simplify it one step at a time so this
is going to be 1 plus h plus 3 plus 2
the h's are going to cancel so that's
going to leave us with one and then now
remember this is the limit as H is
approaching zero if we put 0 in place of
H what do we get we get 4 square root of
4 is 2 plus 2 is 4
so we get 1/4 so what that tells us is
that the instantaneous rate of change ok
the slope okay of the tangent line at
this point 1 comma 2 is going to be 1/4
now if you want to write the equation of
the tangent line
you've got the slope now you have the
point you can use the point-slope form
or the slope-intercept form to find your
equation of your line so I hope this
video helped you go ahead and subscribe
to the channel I'll see you in the
future videos check out some of the
links that I'll put up in the cards so
you can check out some of my past videos
regarding the same topic I'll see you in
the next video